now from randall cunningham to bryce
harper southern nevada is home to many
athletic greats and finley toyota the
sponsors of this next segment along with
the southern nevada sports hall of fame
are here to honor those athletes take a
look
steph it's great to see you you and
finley toyota you guys are part of the
fabric of las vegas how did you get
involved with the southern nevada sports
hall of fame well jc it actually started
at saturn in west sahara
so cliff finley and rich fashion had an
idea to get david hung in duct tape and
so the idea started in 95 96 1995 1996
the 1900s we're going back to uh-huh yes
and in 97 he was our first inductee wow
and then we continued it at findlay
toyota and so from from 97 until now
we've had we've been part of the nevada
sports hall of fame and you guys have
been growing it and growing and growing
the dollar loan center arena by the way
this is my first time here this is
gorgeous inside well we actually have
something really special to show you the
southern nevada sports hall of fame wall
we have an actual wall an actual wall
and i have a hall of famer here with me
today
show me the way all
right steve stallworth you and i'll be
great
nice to see you man nice to see you
thanks for having us on this is an honor
to see you
this wall is spectacular tell me more
about it well we are so proud of how
this all came together jc we have we've
never really had a home home for our
southern nevada sports hall of fame um
there have been uh you know great
supporters of findlay toyota finally
automotive they've housed a lot of our
memorabilia in the past but when we got
the opportunity to actually put this on
display at the dollar loan center we
jumped at the chance uh uh carrie bubold
bill foley they just embraced this 100
so it's more of a wall of fame than it
is a hall of fame but this thing is open
our hall of fame is open for every
publicly ticketed event here at the
dollar loan center uh you know it's
amazing how our families will come in
and just see what's going on we have
over a hundred of our hall of famers all
represented up and down
uh on the wall what year did you go in
so 2019. 2017 is the last class we know
that's correct into the hall of fame
this year we have what six people going
into the hall this year that's correct
so our 2022 class we announced them two
years ago so we're finally going to put
them in uh but it's a great class our
event this year the induction ceremony
is actually on june 17th
right here at the dollar loan center and
anyone can buy tickets absolutely you
want to come and see the athletes go in
hear the speeches
please please uh if you just google
southern nevada sports hall of fame we
popped right up let's walk down and um
and i can tell you this jc our event has
become honestly the sports event in
southern nevada to be at so if you want
to be seen with all the sports community
this is the place to be june 17th and
you're raising money for a really neat
calls for scholarships 100 tell us more
about that so any money that we raise jc
we give
to scholarships for kids that want to
pursue their athletic careers in college
it's vetted through the public education
foundation and these are kids that
honestly embody what we are all about
that's leadership value and character
that they build through sports and jc we
just know that with all of the school
kids all of the athletes they're going
to be looking at this wall you could
have some youngster who admires the wall
and in 25 years they could be up here as
well so we're excited about our hall of
fame and we're excited about the next 25
years as well it's inspiring steve thank
you so much
let's go find your picture up here let's
do it you know where it is where is it
where is it
there we go he's right there my man
the class of 2022 will be entering the
southern nevada sports hall of fame on
june 17th you can purchase tickets at
s-n-a-s-n-s-h-f
dot com he said for me just to google it
you'll find that it'll pop up but it's
gonna be yeah it's gonna be a great
event it's a lot of fun so beautiful in
there stunning to check it out yet it's
stunning inside there you've inspired me
to go see it
well science in action